you ever ripped a skin tag off no I've
never had one I've had one I had one
here
you rip that off ripped it off and what
did it do did it bleed
um no it was it was so like hung off my
face and when I ripped it
was like almost like a clean break yeah
yeah it was like a there's like a
definitely a scar or some [__] but yeah
why does that why did those happen yeah
it's I don't know dude it's uh so you
know AI is going to kill us all and be
like you guys [__] get what skin tags
for how many years have you evolved for
and you still get skin tags you're not
meant to exist dude I can't wait till AI
hijacks all the Teslas and just runs us
all over
the AI War just model X's cut loose
you guys just sitting in your [__]
house and then is here like screaming
and just like tons of like noise you're
like what is that you just look out your
window 300 Tesla Model X full dozing
through your [__] neighborhood just
get them get them no it's 300 Teslas all
playing the Christmas
music
that would be the scariest thing ever
300 Teslas all doing that and they're
like farting instead of their honk you
know and all those like noises you can
make it make yeah Bruh Bruh
and yeah and then they all stop abruptly
and then yeah
and then all their wheels just turn
outward from the street towards you yeah
and they're just killing us all
have you seen uh
what do you think of the Cyber truck
is it coming out
I mean I've seen some tweets about it
apparently like they're it's been
driving around one of the factories man
that [__] ain't coming out you don't
think so no
I do like it though yeah see it was
spotted okay dude
bring doubts about design it looks the
same yeah
how is anyone like suddenly going wait
this isn't good I still think it's cool
that yeah you don't like it
why do you think it's cool I'm curious
this is unique I like the shape of it I
like the Chrome I like the fact that
it's a truck every or possible thing
what every little thing I mean you don't
see Chrome trucks very often yeah hey
man
I know I know I know a custom shop on
the west coast that can get you a chrome
truck tomorrow
you want a chrome Toyota Corolla we can
make that [__] happen dude
we could get you a chrome Toyota Corolla
truck how about that yeah I would do
that you know I don't think this is
coming out
I think you asked me if I like it I yeah
I don't know dude you don't
do you like to pick up trucks I do I
could see how this would be fun to drive
I genuinely can but it's stupid
why is it stupid
oh if you don't do that this looks way
sorry sorry perfect for effect it's
perfect it's perfect
you can sneeze all you want Ryan can you
email HR and yeah
yeah
um subject line ew
subject line severance package
[Laughter]
a chew
I for those listening on audio
um ovie sneezed and it was absolutely
putrid JK JK
don't try to make this cool Luke matte
black cyber truck that's cool the Chrome
one is cool but that's also cool that's
cool
I feel this truck fake
I feel this trunk itches like a like a
younger part of your brain what do you
mean like you're a sentient 30 year old
man and you see this truck you're like
oh wow oh truck cool Truck Yeah it's
shaped like a triangle I'm picturing
myself just doing this with it yeah you
know
like having a small version and just
driving it over my books yeah
yeah of the Cyber truck
I definitely want that
a Duff isn't it crazy how many years has
has been like
teased
didn't you put down the 75 bucks yeah
yeah oh yeah did you ever get that I'm
still in line to get one what's your
position
uh I don't know
but I think I could sell it it was
pretty early it was definitely like on
within the first like few hours
um
so I'm sure when it comes out maybe I
could sell my place in line I don't know
yeah like 2040. yeah if it ever actually
comes out 2019 that truck ain't ever
coming dude
get your [__] 75 back man if you can
yeah I should sue them
that's wild I actually think you can
sell your place online now
can you go go check go check if you can
see what it is
for for fun
you know what a fresh thought that just
came in my mind
that it's not related to anything we may
have just cut out right now it's
completely just a fresh thought what is
it is thinking about how the morning
routine guy is so Advanced car content
is super Advanced I've brought up this
channel before can we uh
uh they're on YouTube I know plumbing
company I always [__] their name up just
type plumbing company car these boys
grind hard Plumbing Co
yeah they come up on my uh YouTube all
the [__] first of all shout out to
these guys they rule I love what they do
um
[__] everything
with a car that you can think of they've
probably done it okay it is insane they
uh they have this scroll up it's it's
their Banner image
look at that you see that Power Wheels
car yeah that's sick that's a like a
Camaro like you like
that thing is actually fast as [__]
um they did one recently where they took
like a Hayabusa motorcycle and they this
was a street bike and they turned it
into a snow a snow bike God damn it
where is it yeah right there dude
this [__] is so upset
that's a street bike on a [__] ski
mountain like
this is the coolest type of content ever
yeah no rules
and the thing that's cool about this is
it takes so much knowledge and
experience to pull this stuff off yeah
and the fact that they do it all
themselves makes it even cooler so cool
yeah Reinhardt Plumbing come
company
um shout out to the Sea boys as well
look them up
yeah see boys
the Crips no I know I know shout out the
[__] yeah shout out shout out all my
looks now these dudes do some crazy [__]
too
but yeah so so this is what it takes to
succeed in car content you're saying
yeah like do crazy you have to do the
most insane [__] that's why
it's funny when people are like because
you know I'm sure you encounter this too
people will talk to me now
it'll be like Oh I'm thinking about
doing this on YouTube like what would
your advice be I'm like take the most
extreme version of that
that's how you get started on YouTube
yeah like if you want to start a podcast
now start a podcast and the whole time
there are people in the room
holding guns to your head
have a good opinion yeah yeah no no no
okay they're they're revolvers and at
the start of the episode
they put a bullet in spin it
and then they're just holding into your
head and at the end of the episode they
pull the trigger oh wow okay and then
every Russian Roulette yeah and every
episode you're like he might go
and then your podcast may go to episode
27. I would watch that yeah
yep look at this we turn a limo into a
hot tub
and this is a year ago man yeah
this is awesome yeah car content I think
um
that's I think that's where I will end
up is doing car content yeah I want to
make so then you can do it to my car
sure yeah yeah yeah I want to you know
let's turn it into something funny
um
yeah we should turn into a demolition
derby car but uh we put a big chain gun
in the middle of it
a gigantic turret yeah yeah we put a
tank turret on top of this car
we're going to a demolition derby today
and they have no idea we're using live
rounds boom
yeah let's do BattleBots but with real
but with real people yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah